orioles will get another look at their
third consecutive lefty
starting for the blue chase and then of
course is stephen matt and steven's been
so hot this is his 24th start of the
season there are his stats in his 23 381
earned run average for him lowest season
era since 2016 for matt's
ground ball down to first dropped and
picked up by vlady and he'll still win
the race one down
went down and got it fly ball to left
and that falls in front of the left
fielder goriel for a base hit
ground ball to third balera short hops
simeon and they won't get two
as valeria kind of elected to get rid of
it quickly rather than setting his feed
and maybe all they would have gotten was
the lead runner but there was no chance
for two on that play
and he got it had to throw a lot of
pitches but no damage done blue jays
coming up when we come back
now harvey goes to work in the bottom of
the first nothing nothing game but after
the all-star break he has been a
different dude
popped him up right side of the infield
jones calling
gloves it marcus simeon steps in one
home run shy of matching his career high
this one is lined at deep left field and
there it is
number 33 for simeon one to nothing blue
jays
and marcus simeon just sizzled
the 204th
of an oriole pitcher
big spot in the early going here for
steven matt's
little pop up shallow right field
dickerson comes on to make the catch oh
and he had the double play at second
if he had seen it
now nobody scored that's the good news
but santander was halfway to third he
could have been doubled off full count
two down
that's to mullins ball four and that'll
get a run in
so give cedric mullins an rbi on the
walk number 49 for him on the season
maria scores and the game's tied at
one three twos inside missed by a lot
ball four another run forced in and the
orioles lead two to one
vermont castle that's rbi number 74.
yeah lots of frustration watch the
reaction knows exactly what he did wrong
trying to
hit that outside corner
change up grounded to short
and michelle make the play to get him
and retire the side ravik valera getting
to start at third base batting in the
nine spot
slashes it down the left field line and
that's a fair ball
and valeria's into second base with a
one-out double that's how you take a
ball a sink or two-seamer away from you
you don't think about trying to pull
that thing you think about staying
behind it
bounce down arias up with it fires and
he got him ramon urrius huh so a nice
play to retire simeon blue jays down in
the third orioles lead at 2-1
glad he's got to reach for it bounces it
up the middle jones is through he's not
in time maddy is smelling base hit and
he gets himself
an infield hit
orioles two blue jays one and here is t
oscar hernandez
a little looper to shallow right and
that's gonna drop besheck get in the way
throw to the plate not in time and
that'll tire blue jays are going to take
advantage of the stolen base by bushette
and then tay oscar hernandez told you
there's a lot of hits over there in
right field
gets jammed on a fastball
and flares it into right field that'll
help you to stay back just a little bit
longer and now it's up to lourdes
gurille jr
to try to give the blue jays the lead
here in the fourth inning and a 3-2
pitch up coming to guriel
lined into left a base hit
hernandez home
dickerson home 4-2 blue jays
oh what an at-bat by lourdes
1-1 pitch
line drive base hit right field
mateo around third has the green light
here comes the throw
and it's cut off he's in
rbi base hit for austin wins and the
orioles get within a run as mateo comes
around now last batter for saucedo
mullins thinking about bunting for a hit
takes a strike throw down got him
alejandro kirk
picks off the runner at first here's
mancini the 1-0 line drive base it to
left field it's going to get in the
corner mount castle digging for third
and they're going to give him the sun
around here comes the relay play at the
plate and mount castle safe and a play
at their base and mancini is out but the
base hit gets the run home the orioles
have tied it up
lopez ready
two on two down
right field santander is there
and lopez does a job comes in gets a
strikeout and guerrero to fly out
a drive to deep center
caught
400 feet away but both runners will tag
in advance
and randall grichik will be batting 1-1
high in the air to center field
medium depth
mullins the catch the shed on his way
home and he will score grechik with a
sacrifice fly it's 5-4 blue jays and
into the game looking for three
enormously important outs for this team
tonight is jordan romano
bechet's got it
scooped by vladi at first for out number
one
he hasn't thrown a slider since coming
into the game
and he got him mullins is unhappy he
thought it was inside
that's out number two
romano trying to put away the orioles
boy it wasn't easy but they got a win
they had to have
finding a way to beat baltimore
five to four
[Applause]
you